reden wir noch kurz über das was am
ersten mai in berlin passiert ist ein
team der heute show hat letzten freitag
bei einer sogenannten hygiene demo
gedreht der name ist vielleicht ein
bisschen irreführend
die fordern noch nicht mehr
seifenspender oder so was man
protestiert gegen korona maßnahmen die
teilnehmer sind ein bunter
verschwörungstheoretiker mix von ganz
links bis ganz rechts gibt sicherlich
auch welche die sich um grundrechte
sorgen aber natürlich auch ganz normale
spinner klar da haben unsere kollegen
jedenfalls gedreht und als sie fertig
waren also quasi nach feierabend auf dem
rückweg zu den autos wurden sie von
einem mob aus 15 bis 20 vermummten
krankenhausreif geprügelt
inzwischen geht es zum glück wieder
einigermaßen also physisch jedenfalls
gebrochene nasen jochbein so was die
berliner staatsanwaltschaft ordnet die
tatverdächtigen dem linken spektrum zu
über das motiv weiß man aber zur stunde
noch nichts abdel karim war unser
reporter vor ort grüßt ich wir sind wir
beide ja gebürtigen ostwestfalen das
heißt man hat uns schon als babys
emotionen ab trainiert das ist unser
großer vorteil wie geht es dir eine
woche später genauer wegen wir die
geschichte sehr gut und es geht mir auch
vor allem gut weil wir schon sagt ist
alle verletzten zu 100 prozent
körperlich fit werden und psychisch
hoffe ich auch du hast ja bevor das
passiert ist erstmal noch ganz normal
deine interviews auf der demo auf der
hygiene demo wie wir das nennen geführt
dass lief aber alles noch sehr fitte und
ab märz lief sehr entspannt sehr
friedlich das material werden wir heute
trotz der schönen gespräche nicht zeigen
das wird gerade vom landeskriminalamt
ausgewertet
dann beschreibt einmal wie lief der
moment der eigentlichen attacke das ging
ja glaube ich alles wahnsinnig schnell
ja das ging ratzfatz wie waren alle im
feierabend modus haben gezielte einem
handy einer trinken kaffee und so weiter
und irgendwann von jetzt auch gleich
kamen mindestens 15
einige sagen sogar 25 ich sag mal
mindestens 15 hochgeschwindigkeit auf
uns zugerannt alle schwarz gekleidet und
vermummt
die meisten zumindest es ging so schnell
man eigentlich gar nicht so richtig man
hätte gar keine chance gehabt die
einzuordnen wer sind die was wollen die
wie gefährlich sind sie haben sie waffen
dabei
wie zombies die schnell rennen können
ist die blödeste kombination haben ja da
hast du das gefühl hat man vorher
ausgespäht weil ich warte ja so ein
bisschen abseits in dem moment jahre für
diese schluss war auch ein bisschen
ärgerlich wir hatten glaube ich die
einzige tote ecke in berlin ausgesucht
in dem moment war erst einmal eine ja
das soll auch der polizist sagte mir
später die ecke muss man finden
wir haben uns nichts dabei gedacht wir
werden die kugel schön ruhig ich kann es
nicht erklären was da los war aber nach
dem vorfall waren sich einige sicherlich
auch das war schon sehr ausgespäht aus
es war für mich also die kam so auf uns
zu die wussten ganz genau hemmungslos
drauf und haben wir keine chance haben
drei brecher dabei waren drei
sicherheitsleute die auch so aussagen
wie sicherheitsleute und die hat die kam
so schnell auf uns zu das die nicht mal
angst zeit haben angst zu kriegen
du bist dann los kann hat die polizei
geholt mein erster gedanke war losrennen
instinktiv das ist einfach so passiert
nach ungefähr 20 meter habe ich
angehalten und mich gefragt jetzt
umdrehen zurücklaufen oder weiter
polizei rennen ich habe mich dann
umgedreht geguckt was da los ist und ich
wusste es wäre vielleicht eine pseudo
heldentat aber es wäre effektiv 0 hilfe
sobald ich aber wusste ist es überall
polizei weil wir wurden quasi
durchgehend von polizei begleitet beim
drehen ja sind wir mal gespannt was da
jetzt noch ermittelt wird es standen
fluchtfahrzeuge bereit das klingt
zumindest nach einer geplanten aktion
sagte er
sherlock holmes in mir für dich war es
tatsächlich erst der zweite dreh als
außenreporter die heute show und dann
gleich so eine scheiße hast hast du dann
trotzdem noch bock für uns zu drehen ins
wettbüro aufstiegsfeier arminia
bielefeld gerne solche geschickt ich
bleibe optimistisch das freut nicht alle
vielen dank dass du hier ist nächste mal
schicken wir dich tatsächlich irgendwo
hin wo es nur schönes bundesgartenschau
oder tatsächlich nach bielefeld keine
ahnung so ihnen zu hause wollte ich an
dieser stelle noch einmal ganz herzlich
danke sagen für die vielen solidarischen
grüße und genesungswünsche die wir sehr
gern ans team weitergeleitet haben
vorgestern gab es bei einer anderen
berliner demo gegen korona maßnahmen
leider den nächsten angriff tritte gegen
einen ard kollegen da fragt man sich
schon ist es wirklich konsequent am
rande von veranstaltungen die sich
angeblich für grundrechte einsetzen
ausgerechnet die pressefreiheit im
wahrsten sinne des wortes mit füßen zu
treten da ist als kleine
denksportaufgabe für kommende demos und
als leicht pastorales schluss vor denn
das war die heute schon jetzt kommt
wir sehen uns nächste woche wieder ist
dahin tschüss schöner
die leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines auto bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut los hast
du scheiße fährt haye